was viele von euch sicher gar nicht
wissen ich bin riesiger Fußballfan von
meinem dritten bis zum 18 Lebensjahr
habe ich selber gespielt und musste dann
leider wegen einer Verletzung im linken
Fingernagel aufhören sonst wäre ich
sicherlich Bundesliga Profi geworden
Fußballs schauen ist aber nach wie vor
eines meiner größten Hobbys und ich
dachte mir ich starte ein weiteres
Format um noch mehr Stadien in ganz
Europa zu entdecken bevor wir starten
wollte ich noch eine Sache loswerden und
zwar müsst ihr natürlich keine Angst
haben dass das jetzt hier ein
fußballkanal wird oder so falls mal so
ein Video kommt wird es natürlich auch
um die Stadt gehen den Ort drumherum die
Reise dahin es passieren sicherlich
viele coole und lustige Sachen ihr habt
nur denke ich an den letzten Videos
gesehen ich versuche jetzt immer mehr
das zu machen worauf ich richtig Bock
habe und was mich so richtig erfüllt und
Fußball ist einfach eine große
Leidenschaft von mir und ein sehr sehr
großes Hobby ich könnte eigentlich jeden
Tag Fußball schauen egal ob erste zweite
dritte Liga in Deutschland ich gucke
sogar vierte Liga teilweise und ich
dachte mir wir probieren das ganze mal
aus an diejenigen von euch die Fußball
überhaupt nicht juckt gibt der Sache
doch gerne mal eine Chance ich glaube
das Video ist ganz cool geworden und
jetzt let's
go so Leute ich befinde mich gerade bei
mir im Büro und hinter mir könnt ihr
eine fußballkarte sehen an dieser dieser
Karte habe ich ohne Scheiß 7 Stunden
dran gesessen ich habe aus fast jeder
europäischen Liga die Fußballvereine
rauskopiert habe dann teilweise das Logo
ausgeschnitten und dort positioniert wo
auch die Stadt vom jeweiligen
Fußballverein ist und jetzt sieht das
halt so aus insgesamt sind das über 200
Fußballvereine aus allen verschiedenen
Ländern mir ist nur aufgefallen ich habe
jetzt hier oben noch Finnland und
Norwegen vergessen aber machen wir beim
nächsten Mal noch mit rein und sonst ist
aber eigentlich wirklich alles dabei und
jetzt ist die Challenge ich werfe und
wir fahren dann dahin wo der PIL landet
und wenn die halt zum nächsten Mal
spielen noch kurz zu den Spielregeln und
zwar muss ich erstens so lange werfen
bis ich wirklich ein Wappen treffe das
heißt wenn ich irgendwo ins Meer werfe
oder auf die weiße Fläche die ja die
Länder sind nehmen wir nicht den Club
der potenziell am nächsten dran ist
sondern werfen noch mal und aus
Platzgründen überlappen sich teilweise
Logos es zählt aber immer das oben
drüber positionierte Logo ich habe
versucht das möglichst fair zu gestalten
so Leute ich habe mich gerade noch kurz
warm gemacht hier haben wir den dartfall
und ich werf jetzt und ja das Ding ist
ich bin kein kübter data es ist sehr
viel weiß also es kann sein dass ist
lange dauert bis ich treffe aber ich
gebe mein Bestes vielleicht habe ich
auch direkt
Glück das war Deutschland aber hier ist
kein Verein ich versuche mal so dahin
zuziielen wo die meisten Waffen
sind das meinte ich nicht aber so in
diesem Bereich hier da ist ja ziemlich
viel und da muss ich ja dann irgendwas
treffen
ah das waroll irgendwo in
Nordsee guck mal ganz knapp an Chelsea
vorbei es wäre fast Chelsea geworden
warte mal guck mal bisschen mehr also
ich würde sagen es ist entweder üdrecht
oder was ist das denn eine Sekunde
eigentlich kenne ich fast alle
fußballwappen auswendig aber das weiß
ich gerade echt nicht ah Anderlecht also
ich würde sagen dieser PIL ist zu 30%
auf üdrecht und zu 70% auf underlicht
wenn ich den jetzt mal rausziehe ja also
es ist auf jeden Fall eher das das ist
echt gar nicht mal so weit ich bin
eigentlich davon ausgegangen wir fliegen
aber ich glaube nach andericht kann ich
sogar fast besser mitm Auto fahren ich
schau jetzt gerade mal nach wann die als
nächstes spielen ich war zumindest noch
was habe ich gerade gesagt Anderlecht
sorry falsch ahnheim das ist das Logo
von ahnheim so sieht's aus ich BL euch
hier ein und die spielen als nächstes am
Samstag den 7.10 um 21 Uhr gegen
exclusive diger WTF kenne ich auch nicht
fünfter Platz ist Rotterdam und ahnheim
ist 12 Platz im Stadion gelredom in
ahnheim ja auf geht's oder dahin nächste
Woche Samstag wir sehen uns er mal für
mich Fußball gucken in Holland in dem
Stadion mal gucken wie es wird so leute
es ist Samstag der
710 das bedeutet heute geht's nach
Arnheim ich war da noch nie und ich habe
richtig Bock wie schon gesagt Arnheim
ist nur 250 km von mir deswegen fahren
wir natürlich mit dem Auto Outfit ist
auf jeden Fall soweit ready ich ma mich
heute ein bisschen schicker und zwar mit
den Produkten von
[Musik]
Holzkern
die haben mir nämlich echt ein paar sehr
nice Accessoires zugeschickt meine Uhr
die ich heute Rocke und Leute ja der
Alex zieht heute eine Kette an dazu dann
noch nices kättchen und wenn wir schon
mal dabei sind auch noch ein nicesces
Armband fresh bin ich schon mal und
jetzt geht's los was geht was geht leute
das ist übrigens Jakob cool dass du
mitkommst wir haben heute richtig Spaß
also ich glaube es wird geil ich habe
bisschen Fußball gucken und so ja ja
also ich Ken zwar die Teams in
Niederlande nicht das ist die Ehra
Devise
die eher der Wiese so heißt das ja ja
erste holländische Liga da geht's
richtig zur Sache also
[Musik]
Abfahrt so Leute wir sind auf jeden Fall
unterwegs Alter es ist echt windig heute
die ersten 80 km haben wir jetzt
geschafft falls euch das was sagt rer
mag um jetzt aber noch mal zurück zu
holzken zu kommen ich blende euch hier
mal die Seite ein es gibt wirklich
zahlreiche Accessoires sei jetzt Ringe
ah übrigens hier ich habe ein Geschenk
für dich guck mal hier beim
Heiratsantrag geil oder muss jetzt ja
sagen du musst den jetzt anziehen und
auch den ganzen Tag tragen steht aber
passt wirklich auch gut ja wirklich
tiptp die Sachen sind natürlich alle
sehr hochwertig produziert es ist super
viel Holz verarbeitet also gut aussehen
tun wir heute auf jeden Fall im Stadion
wenn ihr euch dort was bestellen wollt
mit Alex V 15 gibt's 15% Rabatt
natürlich auch super um irgendwie Leuten
mal eine schnelle Freude zu machen ne
kann man immer gut verschenken sowas
danke ann holzken für Sponsor des Videos
und wir sausen jetzt nach anheim
Fußball das 1:0 für Dortmund ja 10
Dortmund und ist das so als Bayern Fan
wie viel da ist Bayern gerade eigentlich
drit Dortmund eigentlich gerade bestimmt
zweiter frag sich wie lange so Leute
hier kann man schon sehen ahnheim 44 km
sind wir doch glatt gleich schon da also
das Ding echt richtig schnell kurze
Anreise wir haben mal kurz ein
fahradtausch gemacht und jetzt heißt es
noch eine halbe Stunde bis ahnheim mal
gucken was wir da dann noch so machen
weil das Fußballspiel ist erst heute
Abend um 21 Uhr ich bin mal gespannt auf
die Stadt wie gesagt ich war da noch nie
aber es wird sicher
geil
[Musik]
so leute schaut mal hier Netherlands da
sind wir geil jetzt geht's hier nach
steht gar nicht drauf jetzt bitte nicht
zu schnell fahren weil hier ist 120 und
Blitzer sind teurer als in Deutschland
ich muss sagen ich finde die Hotels in
Holland immer so spannend dieses Hotel
das kenne ich auch noch früher von
Fußballturnieren wir haben immer in
Holland Fußballturniere gehabt und man
hat wirklich super viele so hohe Hotels
einfach neben der Autobahn das gibt's ja
in Deutschland eigentlich gar nicht wir
sind heute übrigens Imbis Hotel
eingebucht so das sieht doch alles sehr
holländisch hier aus oder schön ne ja
wirklich also schöne Häuschen süße Stadt
ja Holland hat ja eigentlich ist ja
überall so bekannt für den tollen
Baustil ne kommt ja alles aus der
Barockzeit und so wir das hier alles
gebaut alles Barockzeit hab auch Bock
die haben auch gute Ultras Vitesse
Arnheim habe ich schon mir Videos
angeguckt kann eigentlich von jedem
Bundesligisten außer Hoffenheim und
Leipzig ein Fangesang auswendig und
sogar von vielen Zweitligisten auch und
ahnheim auf geht's ahnheim schießentor
h haben wir vielleicht schon den ersten
Spieler von dem Team was ist das für ein
Logo aus nach intermailand oder so nee
die spielen h glaube ich nicht so Leute
angekommen im schönsten Parkhaus von
ganz Arnheim hast du alles ja ich glaube
jetzt habe ich alles super so dann
machen wir uns mal auf ins Hotel also
ich glaube das ist mit eins der besten
ebis Hotels was ich hier gesehen
[Musik]
habe guck mal sogar h können sogar drei
schlafen das war super und mit perfekten
Blick auf McDonald's Küche
Spiegel ein Bett zwei Bett Fernseher
also ich sag mal so Hotel hat jetzt 144
€ die Nacht gekostet ist okay ich glaube
das liegt auch daran weil wir Wochenende
haben natürlich jetzt ziehen wir uns
kurz um wobei ich habe eigentlich eh nur
ein Outfit dabei und dann geht's los
erstmal in der Stadt was essen und dann
ab zum Fußball fre mich auf Stadion wir
bestimmt geil Badezimmer ist auf jeden
Fall auch nicht verkehrt hallih hallo
wir gehen jetzt erstmal auf die
Dachterrasse noch was trinken du musst
noch eben die Uhr wechseln so endlich
sieht so gut
aus
so
aufim also ich muss sagen man hat hier
wirklich ein sehr sehr schönen Ausblick
Leute
geil aber schon
windig ist auch gar nicht mal so groß
also hier gibt es nur so 150.000
Einwohner wirkt aber so vom Stadtbau
deutlich größer als z.B eine Stadt mit
150.000 Einwohnern in Deutschland aber
vom Ibis Hotel bin ich echt überzeugt
also falls sie mal nach Arnheim kommt ja
ist das eine Location wo man schlafen
kann und gleich testen wir den besten
Burger der beste Burger aus ganz Holland
Leute und ihr wisst ich liebe Burger
schmeckt das Bier ja ja für für ein
passenden
herbsteinklangieren so Leute
mittlerweile in Arnhem zentral das sieht
ja auch gut aus hier gibt's überall Paps
guck mal da K mal später noch hingehen
wir sind aber gerade auf dem Weg zum
besten Burgerladen in ganz Holland und
den checken wir jetzt mal aus eigentlich
sieht es in in
sieht sehr ähnlich aus wie hier noch
weiter in der Innenstadt also man muss
wirklich sagen Arnheim ist total cool
leute fahrt nach Arnheim und wenn jetzt
noch das Fußballspiel später geil wird
dann ist es wirklich rund um eine
gelungene Stadt ah
hier
so Leute Burger sind da ich habe
normalen Cheeseburger ja angry Angs
Burger das ist der beste Burger aus ganz
Holland 2019 gewesen also Leute Burger
ist okay aber ich hätte Deutsch mehr
erwartet na ja kann man nichts machen so
aufgegessen haben wir also uns wurd ja
im Hotel gesagt dass das der beste
Burger im letzten Jahr in ganz Holland
war wie fandst du den Burger S von nicht
se von ze wenn das der beste war dann
will ich gar nicht gar nicht wissen wie
der zweitbesse schmeckt weil der war
echt nichts also wir haben aber schon
eine Vermutung woran es liegt warum das
der Platz 1 Burger in ganz Holland ist
und weil die waren
[Musik]
super so kurz noch in der Bar und dann
geht's gleich zum Spiel hinter uns
trinken schon die Vitesse Arnheim Fans
ordentlich vor und wir haben uns jetzt
mal so bisschen undercover dazu gesellt
weil wir sind natürlich heute auch für
die heilmannschaft cheers ich habe jetzt
schon getrunken egal
Nummer D man muss sich ja auf Fußball
auch immer einstimmen ne und Leute in
den letzten Videos ging es richtig wenig
um Bier deswegen kann ich mir das heute
mal wieder gönnen
Fußball wir sind jetzt auf jeden Fall
Mitten hier auf der Brücke unter uns ist
ein Fluss und da sieht man jetzt die
Skyline von anenheim und da vorne da
leuchtet und da ist das Stadion da
müssen wir hin genau noch da hinten okay
Leute wir sind da das gelrodom irgendwie
sieht's komisch aus ne also für ein
Stadion für ein Fußballstadion könnte
auch eine Fabrik sein oder irgendwie so
was ne so wir sind jetzt genau vom
Stadion was sagst du was dein Eindruck
welche Mannschaft ja natürlich hier die
Heimmannschaft vitesse also gegen
Rotterdam ja nur man muss sagen hier
spielt nicht nur wieitest ahnheim
sondern auch irgendwelche Bands es sieht
halt auch echt nicht aus wie ein
Fußballstadion mus man einfach sagen
sondern mehr wie so eine Eventhalle
Jakob Fanshop hier wir brauchen noch
zwei
Schals da vorne sind auch noch schs
warte mal ja
komm was geht so ich habe jetzt hier
natürlich heimschal ähnlich so wie bei
Borussia Dortmund 15 € gekostet du hast
den auswärtsschal auch 15 € sieht aus
wie westham aber na ja Hauptsache nicht
Dortmund ich bin auch echt mal gespannt
wie voll das da drin ist weil das
Stadion hat Plätze für 30.000 Leute ich
gehe mal nicht davon aus dass
ausverkauft ist wäre natürlich geil wenn
die Stimmung gut ist also Pyro Problem
haben die hier nicht man wird nicht malh
kontrolliert wir sind so gerade noch
rechtzeitig ne
so was sind unsere Plätze 56 57 ja
irgendwie so ist do Top oder ist war
nicht so viel los aber so auf
aheim vitesse vitesse also der
heimsupport vorm Spiel ja ich hätte mir
auf jeden Fall mehr erhofft und da
hinten haben wir ganz klar RW Leipzig
aus na ja auf ein geiles
Spiel so an Spiel läuft auf geht ahnheim
kämpfen und Ziegen oh jetzt darf
Hoffenheim da oben auch lernen vitesse
alleitesse alle guck mal kann ich schon
den Z K
so
ja
schieß oh mann ey
wohin
ja 11 m 11 geil Jungs
super ja ganz klar hab von hier gesehen
komm mach ihn junge mach ihn steh noch
in Verbindung mit dem Kölner Keller mal
gucken ob das hier auch so lange dauert
wie in Deutschland oh man scheiß
DFB scheiße scheiße ach guck mal hier
ist direkt der Monitor ey wie cool schon
interessant oder schon auch nah dran ne
ja ja der zieht den zurück ja ah
m so ein Scheiß
ey
Alter das war aber eng jetzt die
rotterdammer die machen jetzt so langsam
Druck hier kte
ge also was auch sehr holländisch
ausseht sind die beiden Coaches da an
der Seitenlinie nee hier die Trainer der
ist auf jeden Fall Holler
durch ist
von
leuteim wirklich kein gutes Spiel
rotterdam ist klar überlegen gute
takkans Hal Zeit und dann geht das schon
die bräuchten vielleicht auch mal ein
Bierchen in der Pause das W das wä gut
für
Spiel weiter weiter
[Applaus]
weiter
[Musik]
haben
V also man muss sagen redll Leipzig
dreht mittlerweile richtig am Rad da
oben Karte Karte Karte gebe gelbe Karte
[Musik]
gebe sogar die Ultras sind jetzt schon
Oberkörper
frei also wenn das Spiel hier wirklich 0
ausgeht dann bin ich super traurig ja
das wäre dann mein drittes Spiel in
Folge ich war Mittwoch noch in Dortmund
gegen Mailand was 0
[Applaus]
ausgegangen
[Gelächter]
Käse ist wunderbar okay freistuss für
[Applaus]
Rotterdam nein ey m das gibt's nicht ja
[Musik]
giert
ja oh mann ey das kann doch nicht da
sein man man M M M M M ey da fahren wir
hier 250 km um un so
Schi hier laufen die ganze Zeit Lieder
die man auch in Deutschland kennt nur
mit demem anderen
Text na ja ich sag mal so auch in
schlechten Zeiten werden wir dich STS
begleiten wie tesse wir sind immer für
dich da eine Sache die ich noch kurz
anmerken wollte selbst in der dritten
Liga in Deutschland wenn jetzt hier das
Auswärtsteam rauskommt ist hier was los
und hier juckt irgendwie gar keinen das
ist ein bisschen schade finde ich aber
trotzdem eine sympathische Mannschaft
exelio Rotterdam ja bis den
organisationstechnisch kann man den
Holländern aber nichts vormchen wir
kommen ohne Probleme jetzt hier weg wir
mussen nicht mal was bezahlen für diesen
Bus
[Musik]
super
le
[Musik]
so Leute guten Morgen Ich bin gerade
aufgestanden wir sind gerade
aufgestanden haben auch schon 12 Uhr wir
müssen jetzt hier ganz schnell raus die
machen ganz schön Stress auf jeden Fall
waren wir gestern auch ein paar Bars war
eigentlich ganz lustig ne ja gegeben
jetzt gehen wir noch was essen leider
war es ein 00 Spiel das ist natürlich
ein bisschen schade aber im Großen und
Ganzen war Trepp auf jeden Fall nicht
verkehrt so leute wir befinden uns hier
gerade am Busbahnhof haben wir auch
geparkt jetzt geht's nach Hause das
war's mit unserem Ausflug hier nach
Arnheim ich muss sagen mir hat's gut
gefallen ich bin ein bisschen fertig von
gestern ich hoffe euch hat das Video
auch gefallen danke Jakob fürs mitkommen
und wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder
mal gucken wo es dahin geht und wenn ihr
Bock habt dass ich sowas öfter mache
schreibt gerne mal in die Kommentare
lasst nach oben da und abonnieren
natürlich ne gro ich trinken jetzt
meinen Kaffee und dann fahren wir jetzt
zweieinhalb Stunden nach Hause dann war
das auch schon entspannte Rückfahrt ja
bis dahin RBE Karte gebe vitesse wir
fahren jetzt gerade aus ahnhheim raus
und jetzt kommen wir hier noch mal am
Stadion vorbei bei Tageslicht hier sind
wir gestern den ganzen Weg zu Fuß
gelatscht da haben wir es doch den
gilredrom Sim Dunkeln eigentlich cooler
aus ne ja eigentlich muss man festhalten
ein schönes Fußballstadion ist es nicht
gibt schönere aber die Stadt Arnheim
super